>> Greg: OF THE DEBATE TONIGHT
IS LIKE A FREEWAY WITH A LOT OF
DRIVERS GOING SOMEWHERE TERRIBLE
IN A HURRY.
THE PROBLEM IS, THAT LANE IS NOW
BACKED UP.
ENGINES ARE REVVING, GOING
NOWHERE GOOD.
IF ONLY ONE OR TWO CANDIDATES
CHECKED THEIR SIDE VIEWS AND
CHECKED THAT VACANT MIDDLE LANE,
THEY'D HOPPED RIGHT TO THE
FRONT.
THAT'S THE THING ABOUT SANITY,
IT'S ATTRACTIVE TO THE REST OF
US WHO CAN SEE WHERE THAT LANE
GOES.
NOW, A MOVEMENT TO THE MIDDLE
LANE WOULD MAKE SENSE, BUT THE
MEDIA WILL TICKET YOU FOR ANY
INFRACTION THAT MIGHT COME WITH
EXPRESSING ANY MODERATE VIEWS.
RACISM, SEXISM, THOSE ARE THE
LABELS.
THAT'S WHERE THE FAR LEFT LANE
TAKES YOU, WHICH IS WHERE YOU
FIND ALL THE SHEEP, FOR NOW.
IN THAT LANE, MISTAKING THE
ATTENTION FROM THE PRESS.
INSTEAD, IT ONLY REPRESENTS THE
SCREW JUST VOICE OF THE PRESS
AND SOCIAL MEDIA, WHO ARE NOW
THE LOUDEST VOICES AT THE PARTY.
ONE IS HEADING THE WRONG WAY,
THE OTHER CHEERING THEM ON, KNOB
DOMINIC NEVER PAUSING TO CHECK T
DOMINIC NEVER PAUSING TO CHECK E
DAMAGE THEY LEAVE BEHIND.
IT'S A SLOW COMMUTE.
WHEN YOU DO WITH YOUR DOORS
LOCKED.
EMMANUEL SAID THIS ABOUT THE
2020 DEMOCRATS.
SO OFTEN, YOU RESORT TO CHASING.
>> Juan: I CAN'T BELIEVE THAT
GREG IS ASKING ME ABOUT
SOCIAL MEDIA.
CALL MANAGEMENT.
>> Greg: THAT'S WHAT YOU'VE
BEEN SAYING, THOUGH.
>> Juan: THE PROBLEM FOR ME
IS, I CAME FROM A TIME WHEN
CAMPAIGNS WERE REALLY ABOUT NEW
CYCLES, AS OPPOSED TO COMPULSIOC
CYCLES, AS OPPOSED TO COMPULSIOM
CYCLES, AS OPPOSED TO COMPULSIOU
CYCLES, AS OPPOSED TO COMPULSIOS
CYCLES, AS OPPOSED TO COMPULSIOV
CYCLES, AS OPPOSED TO COMPULSIO
COMPULSIVE.
IT WORKS.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT THESE THINGS
HAVE REAL IMPACT.
I MEAN, YOU LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENS
TODAY.
I THINK IT'S CARTY B HAD AN
INTERVIEW, RIGHT?
GUESS WHAT.
2.4 MILLION PEOPLE?
THAT'S UNBELIEVABLE TO ME.
>> Greg: YOU ARE A BIG CARTY B
FAN, SO THAT'S GOING TO
INFLUENCE YOU.
>> I DO ADMIRE HER.
SHE ACTUALLY HAS SAT DOWN, DONE
INTERVIEWS.
SHE IS THOUGHTFUL.
I THINK IT'S NOT JUST THE MEDIA
THAT'S PUSHING THEM.
I THINK IT'S TWITTER.
THE THING ABOUT JOE BIDEN, ON
TWITTER, HE GETS TRASHED.
BUT HE IS GOING UP IN THE POLL.
I WONDER, WAIT, IS HE THE
ESTABLISHMENT THAT'S GOING TO BE
PROVED WRONG?
IT'S THE ONE I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT BIDEN'S PREDICAMENT.
HE FACES TWO OF THEM.
THIS IS WHAT THEY ARE.
NUMBER ONE, BIDEN IS LIKABLE,
BECAUSE HE IS ON DIFFERENT
UNDISCIPLINED.
WHAT WE ALL LIKE ABOUT HIM IS HE
IS GRABBY AND SANE WRONG THINGS
ALL THE TIME, BUT HE HAS TO BE
NEAR PERFECT TOMORROW IN ORDER
TO GET BY.
I DON'T THINK THAT YOU CAN KIND
OF TURNED THAT SWITCH OFF AFTER
SO MANY YEARS.
THE SECOND THING IS, WHEN BIDEN
IS ATTACKED, HE GETS SUPER
FRANTIC AND DEFENSIVE AND STARTS
TO SPIT FIRING ALL OF HIS
LEGISLATIVE RUNDOWN'S FOR THE
LAST THREE DECADES.
IT COMES OFF AS EXTREMELY CRAZY
AND UPTIGHT AND WILD AND
DEFENSIVE.
BUT HE NEEDS TO REMAIN CALM WHEN
HE IS ATTACKED LIKE THAT.
BUT TRUMP'S IN HIS HEAD, BECAUSE
HE'S SUPPOSED TO BE SLEEPY JOEL,
SO HE CAN'T ACT CALM.
HE CAN'T RISE ABOVE IT AND ACT
STURDY AND STUDY OR THE NAME
SLEEPY JOEL WILL STICK.
>> Juan: YOUR TIMES UP.
SPEAK OF THE DEBATES AT
8:00 P.M.
>> Greg: THIS IS THE
UNDERCARD, KATIE.
NOBODY SHOULD REALLY BE WATCHING
THIS.
THEY SHOULD BE WATCHING TUCKER
AND HANNITY.
WATCHED THE THURSDAY HIGHLIGHTS.
>> I'M SURE THAT THE NONBIASED
MODERATORS.
I THINK THE MOST INTERESTING
POINT IS HOW THEY HAVE AFFECTED
MICHIGAN.
DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN FRANTICALLY
TRYING TO GET THOSE VOTERS BACK
IN THEIR CORNER.
ALMOST EVERY SINGLE DEMOCRAT
RUNNING AGAINST HIM HAS SAID
THAT THEY ARE GOING TO APPEAL
THOSE.
25% OF PEOPLE IN MICHIGAN, 25%
WAS THE AVERAGE TAX CUT IN
MICHIGAN.
THAT'S A LOT.
THERE ARE 200,000 PEOPLE WHO ARE
NOW NO LONGER PAYING.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT JOE BIDEN
HAS TALKED ABOUT DEFENDING AND
BRINGING BACK.
I THINK WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
POLICY POSITIONS, THEY ARE GOING
TO BE GOING AFTER
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO TRY TO KEEP
THE FOCUS OFF THE WAR GOING ON
WITH THE LEFT.
I'M NOT SO SURE THAT THEY ARE
GOING TO MAKE AN IMPACT.
>> Juan: YOU HAVE SANDERS
VERSUS WARREN.
WARREN HAS ALREADY COME OUT WITH
SOME ENDORSEMENTS THAT USED TO
GO TO BERNIE SANDERS.
>> BUT SHE DOESN'T HAVE CARTY B.
>> Juan: NO, SHE DOESN'T HAVE
CARTY B.
AS YOU KNOW, SHE'S GOING UP IN
THE POLLS BACK.
>> I'M SO CONFUSED ABOUT CARTY B
THOUGH, BECAUSE SHE DID THAT
RANT ABOUT TAXES.
SO TOO DON'T KNOW.